hi my name is Pavel ilaria I'm a
technology entrepreneur i'm the founder
of loretta nova which is a tech
conference on innovation internet and
entrepreneurship where latin america
meets the world this conference is being
held in madrid next june 15 and 16 and
in são paulo brazil next november so
basically the question i would like to
answer is about latin america has one of
the highest youth unemployment rates in
the world how can latin america increase
opportunities for young people so
basically i think entrepreneurship
should be the solution for unemployment
we have to create and think what kind of
really interesting things you can do
thanks to the internet for example
there's a company called mercadolibre
which is a biggest e-commerce side and
latin america and they have just
launched mercado shops which mean that
anyone can build their own e-commerce
platform ecommerce site for free let's
just get a commission when you sell your
products and they help you also with all
the the payment system so basically
think about of any for any product or
service that you would like to sell then
you can go to mercado shops and get your
own e-commerce site for free so
basically technology I think that
empower people can empower the youth and
basically the youngest generation is
they want a much better use technology
and can innovate so basically my
recommendation is to self-employed think
about a new idea and you think that your
community could need and you can have
your own
shop online commerce site in just one
hour that's my advice thank you so much